bonjour à tous il ya du changement dans
la gamme galaxy a chez samsung avec la
fin du samsung galaxy à saint luc et
l'arrivée d'un tout autre modèle mais ça
je vais vous le dire
[Musique]
au revoir samsung galaxy à 5 bonjour
samsung galaxy à 8 et a8 plus alors un
changement non un changement de numéro
en réalité mais qui en dit long qui dit
beaucoup de choses sur le choix
stratégique et sur l'avenir des produits
d'entrée de gamme de chez samsung ces
symptômes on connait la gamme s qui est
là pour les produits haut de gamme le
samsung galaxy s uite suis plus ça ne
vous aura pas échappé parce que en début
2017 c'est vraiment les produits qui ont
marqué un nouveau pas pour s'inscrire
dès que l'écran infiniti borderless il
ya aussi le samsung galaxy note 8 qui
est sorti il n'y a pas très longtemps et
le samsung galaxy à 5 qui a été revue
pour une version 2010 est et qui change
vraiment dont alors pourquoi est ce si
important pour samsung de passer d'une
aux galaxies à 5 aux galaxies à 8 et a8
plus parce qu'en réalité il y aura deux
modèles quand on voit que samsung pour
ses modèles avant son numéro le 6 6 6 7
7 âge ensuite on se retrouve sur 1 à 5
de 2016 et 2017 on a l'impression que
c'est un modèle qui évolue pas on voit
qu'il ya un très très gros
positionnement des modèles chinois sur
les produits d'entrée de gamme au nord
huawei one plus j'en passe et des
meilleurs c'est très important pour
samsung s'ils veulent rester en place
sur les produits d'entrée de gamme de
changer quelques détails en commençant
par le nom de ce produit il faut
imaginer des produits haut de gamme
comme le f8 et suit plus et note suite
non pas du tout ce travail et de la même
manière que des produits d'entrée de
gamme déjà parce que vous n'avez pas la
même concurrence sont toutes dans
l'entrée de gamme vous avez une
concurrence qui est énorme d'autant plus
que ce changement nous parler vraiment
de colère ce qu'on retrouve sur les
produits haut de gamme vous avez comme
je vous disais vous avez le galaxy s
suite elle suit plus note 8 l'iphone 8
alors l'idée d'abord galaxie à 8 et à
l'huile plus et ben ça peut paraît tout
bête mais d'un point de vue marketing
pour le consommateur on est sur les
numéros 8 les numéros du moment il faut
plus réfléchir par rapport à la
concurrence son entrée de gamme vous
avez le wild + 5 et 5 tu es maintenant
si samsung grèce sur un galaxy à 5 et là
on a l'impression qu'ils se rapproche un
peu du one + 5 t à leurs qualités il
faut qu'il s'en détache pour pouvoir
apparaître comme étant un modèle en tout
cas sur le papier rien qu'avec le nom
plus puissant plus sexy et plus
intéressant d'où vient cette information
l arrivée de plusieurs sources elle
vient du site ou une future en sites
allemands qui donne des croquis très
intéressant de ce break 6 à 8 et en huit
minutes il ya eu une autre source
également des infos qui fuitent au
compte gouttes mais qui sont confirmées
par des sources très proches de samsung
techniquement qu'est ce que ce samsung
galaxy à 8 et a8 plus rond dans le
ventre alors le a8 plus ça sera le grand
modèle avec un grand écran 6 pouces
super amoled fhd plus haut ratio 18/9 un
processeur exynos 7885 est d'accord à
2,2 giga hertz le18 plus je devais avoir
6 giga de ram et 64 giga de stockage il
devrait tourner sous un android 7 - pour
un nougat avec l'interface samsung
expérience 8.5 et l'ouest devraient
pouvoir est mise à jour vers android 8.0
oreo il vraiment une batterie 3500
milliampères heures et une charge rapide
un bluetooth 5.0 une certification ip68
qui assurent qu'ils résistant à l'eau et
à la poussière une prise jack de l'usb
type c on devrait trouver un double
capteur photo à l'avant à 16 mégapixels
et 8 mégapixels et à l'arrière un 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de 1.7
donc un objectif créer lumineux on sait
que ça me souviens vraiment acteurs de
faire des produits qui font de belles
photos de toute façon aujourd'hui les
photos sur un smartphone ça fait partie
du coeur l'utilisation autant européen
peut s'en moque et d'avoir un bluetooth
5.0 4.2 autant faire de belles photos
captées des souvenirs faire des scènes
fit partager des choses ça c'est
primordial et samsung l'a bien compris
on va retrouver le scanner d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller à l'arrière
juste sous l'appareil photo ça c'est
dommage toujours très dommage j'espère
d'ailleurs que sur le samsung galaxy s
meuf qui sortira l'année prochaine on
devrait retrouver un peu plus bas tout
simplement parce que lorsque vous
cherchez à déverrouiller vous risquez de
poser votre doigt sur votre capteur ça
c'est normal et juste au dessus sur
l'appareil photo
coup laissé des traces sans l'objectif
ça veut dire le nettoyer tout le temps
ça veut dire des photos doivent être
forcément très lettre c'est pas idéal de
son côté le galaxy à 8 aura un écran un
peu plus petit en 5,7 pouces un peu
moins de puissance de ram ou les 36
gilles garon sera un 4 gigas et qu'on
devrait pouvoir retrouver en 32 gigas de
stockage mais aussi en 64 go de stockage
tout en sachant toute façon vous allez
pouvoir rajouter une carte microsd pour
monter normalement jusqu'à 256 go de
stockage c'est un produit qui devrait
être dévoilé au cs en janvier à las
vegas alors moi je vous invite à vous
abonner parce que au csj serez
et ce produit je vais aller le voir et
je vous dirai tout en avant première
comme ça je le prendrais en main je le
testerai je vous dirais s'il est bien
oui non si la photo c'est sexy s'il
tourne vous serez tous et toutes les
infos en avant-première abonnez vous si
on doit regarder par rapport à ce qui a
été annoncé au premier tour sorti ya pas
longtemps ce samsung fasse et samsung
galaxy à 8 et a8 plus on réellement deux
concurrents tout d'abord vous avez le
one + 5 t qui a un grand écran 6 pouces
full optique amoled de 18 9e en 1080 par
2160 pixels un double capteur arrière
avec une ouverture de 1.76 giga de ram
64 giga de stockage une batterie 3500
milliampères heures vous avez également
le honor view dit ce qui a été annoncé
il ya très très peu de temps qui reprend
sensiblement les mêmes caractéristiques
un écran 5,99 pouces fhd plus au format
18 9e sur une dalle ips1 double capteur
photo à l'arrière avec une ouverture en
9.81 des caractéristiques techniques qui
sont sensiblement proche pour l'instant
le one + 5 t n'a pas trop de soucis à se
faire parce qu'il est déjà commercialisé
on dise que le galaxy à 8 à 8 plus et le
honor yunist sortiront que l'année
prochaine ça va être un vrai combat un
vrai fight on va regarder ça de plus
près je vais aller voir comme je voulais
dit au cs je serai présent je vais
regarder tous ces modèles on va les
comparer et on sera un guide d'achat
pour les modèles d'entrée de gamme de
début 2018 dites moi ce que vous en
pensez ce que c'est des produits qui
pourraient vous intéresser est ce que
vous êtes déjà possesseurs de samsung
galaxy à 5 est ce que le a8 et a8 plus
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que les
avoir une grande dalle d'avoir des
modèles qui c'est et comment ce contenu
sympa plus joli et puis corresponde
vraiment dans les standards qui sont en
train de se développer actuellement
dites moi ce que vous en pensez je vous
invite à laisser jolie pousse à vous
abonner parce que comme je voulais dit
je serai aux crs et il y aura énormément
de surprises on va voir toutes les
nouveautés high-tech en avant première
on va les tester on fera énormément de
choses et puis il y aura encore d'autres
surprises mais c'est un truc un peu plus
tard abonnez vous vous dis à très
bientôt d'ici là soyez sages portez vous
bien je vous embrasse
[Musique]